[Musique]
j'en ai assez
il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas oui
il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas donc
oui et peut-on savoir ce qui ne va pas
mon pauvre léo noir et que si elle est
que faut-il faire si on veut il suffit
que les ponceaux renard me rendra fou
léonard je te demande à genoux ah non
pardon il ya trop de poussière je te
demande de boue qu'est ce qui ne va pas
j'ai envie de distraction je m'ennuie
dans cette malle eh bien on va faire un
cours dans le jardin
hélas je me suis tendue ce matin à
cheville et je ne peux m'en sortir
jusqu'à demain et bien grave sur mes
épaules un coup on s'est trop non j'ai
le vertige en casimir porte moi le
châtain jusqu'ici
quoi mais enfin et mais ici c'est
presque comme le jardin regarder il y à
des plantes des fleurs et même un arbre
arrêts mais il n'y a pas le kiosque le
banc les ballons
doucement trouvera quand même pas que je
t'apporte ici l'occurrence que le banc
lé ballon c'est bien sûr à moins que tu
sois pas mon âme est ainsi bien sûr je
me souviens en nominant mais mais mais
mais tu me laisserait presque infirme
avec ma tristesse son rang le petit
service que je te demande parce que toi
tu appelle ça un petit service du pain
qui n'ont pas dit en tant que mesure
tout petit qu'un dis-je bon bah écoute
tu as raison que tu as un ami alors il
est normal que je te rends service bon
c'est évident je vais y aller
ne serait pas trop aux émirats tout à
l'heure
c'est vrai après tout on ne peut pas
refuser à un service à des amis même
s'ils sont un peu casse-pieds bon magie
vais
julien petit moment non désolé julie
mais j'ai 150 ballons à gonfler lors
d'une rencontre que dans ces conditions
j'ai autre chose à faire qu'à bavarder
ça ne me rend pas vraiment compte enfin
tant pis
exceptionnellement je vais ranger monkey
allemand bravo il analysera
[Applaudissements]
mais dans ma chaise y'a plus rien et à
10 par un mais j'ai dit non
mais tu vas tu
mystères inexplicablement lyon montchat
france invoqué de 6 avant d'envoyer
savoir qu'à un mystère paraît toujours
et l'expliquer oui c'est qu'en fait les
jo les trouver mais caméléon c'est vrai
bon alors que yacine d'équipé mais
également ma chère tu t'agites aaron
greenberg a gagné à milan je comprends
rien eh bien venez avec nous et vous
jugerez par vous même
mais
ont disparu
bien
les jambes la météo sur le
banc il a disparu
bons d'achats casimir photo léonard
[Rires]
me suis dit nabédé nous
[Musique]
je l'appelle du tarn on a tous voila
mais vous voyez pas
il a le droit il fait gris pâle
en
somme on arrive à pluton
[Musique]
moi ce que j'aime c'est ne rien faire
rien du tout
c'est ce que je préfère par dessus tout
en fait je suis une lectrice de plafond
oui c'est ma vraie nature
enfin lectrice de gazon parce que les
plats fouilles
moi j'aime les choses simples regarder
les gens passer les voir vivre les
observer savoir qu'ils sont ce qu'ils
font ils bon d'où ils viennent qu'est ce
qu'ils ont dans la tête dans les mains
dans les poches à quoi ils rêvent à
qu'ils pensent leurs espoirs leurs
ennuis leurs envies
comment il parle comment il mange
comment ils dorment enfin tout quoi
j'aime les gens
que ça puisque ce serait mon rêve
ce serait d'être dans la poche de
quelqu'un pense qu'il s'en apercevoir or
quel bonheur ce serait
[Musique]
j'aime les contacts les échanges en 7 6
1 je rêve de pouvoir communiquer avec le
premier venu
pour compenser tout il
inquiète une attendu monsieur martin ce
matin il m'a dit je vais patiner le
goujon ce soin il n'est pas encore entré
en bété que je le sache je ne suis pas
dans sa chemise mois et la vie privée de
monsieur martin ne m'intéresse pas
matin
ouf
voilà
alors leona tu es content
à moitié seulement à moitié seulement
comment tu voulais la le kiosque lobant
les ballons la chaise de joints tu les
as que faut-il de plus à casimir
réfléchit un peu tous ces objets sans
françois juni et monsieur du sne hommes
ne sont rien allez venez chercher quand
nous voir à l'endroit du désert ne l'a
pas vraiment tout 16 heures
bon bon bon bon j'y vais
des gentils casimir us comme casimir on
en fait peu
ma chaise
merci mes amis d'être venus si vite
merci
et que s'est il passé
vous n'êtes pas au courant
j'avais envie de tout cela et de votre
présence également
mais tout ça n'est pas vous tout seul
c'est casimir qui a fait le travail vous
ne saviez pas mais j'ai la cheville
tordue et je ne dois pas marché avant
demain où tu aurais pu en fermant les
yeux et imaginez le jardin je manque
totalement d'imagination
qui va apporter tous au jardin nous en
avons besoin et bien si moi je n'ai pas
d'imagination je sais que vous en avez
beaucoup retourner là bas fermez les
yeux et imaginez que tout est en place
l'est au nord
avec cela nous n'avons rien à fond
je ne sais pas si nous avons eu raison
de laisser à léonard le kiosque le banc
les ballons et tout le reste
le jardin est aussi désert qu'un music
hall 1 un music hall en mai vous me
donnez unis les lames celui snob je vais
vous improviser un spectacle
asseyez-vous
[Musique]
oui
avec tout un champ ton
imagination
je vous emmène dans le thriller
du bonheur
[Musique]
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monde ribéry
je m'appelle casini
la bombe couleur orange je suis aussi
donc un an
si l'on me ni maladroit
pour moi
je sais jouer dans la belgique
je suis né se marient mme camille si
j'aime la glace son choix c'est qu'on
voit c'est mon droit
avec une chanson
un peu d'imagination
je vous emmène dans notre rythme on fait
du bonheur tranquille
[Musique]
ces coûts peuvent rencontrer
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le bon sens qui fait rire
je m'appelle quasi vie
j'ai une malle magique
elle une idée fantastique
je mange du gloubiboulga des jeunes
femmes
j'ai mené la campagne
j'ai vu la ville de caen cannes ie6 mais
même aux quatre étoiles c'est mon droit
trois
chansons
un peu d'imagination
[Musique]
emmène dans notre île
boehner en pis
découvert au complet
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le bon sens qui fait rire
je m'appelle casini
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]